[Music]
the Titanic has been lying on the
Atlantic sea bed since 1912 the much
heralded luxury liner collided with an
iceberg on its maiden voyage and sank
now yadegar SEC has immortalized what
was once the world's largest passenger
ship in a huge panorama this is entire
statement it's a great subject the
Titanic was a genuine symbol of the
euphoria about modern things back then
but a tragedy too it's a bizarre type of
beauty it happened over a century ago
and we haven't forgotten the accident
but it invites other thoughts to the
could send us off thinking were really
just one small part of the universe
Gattaca SEC had to content himself with
photographs and maps when he did his
research because no one is allowed to
dive down to the Titanic anymore the
wreck is lying in complete darkness on
the seabed so the artist needed to
lighten things up a bit
which is sure I'd like to retain a
certain element of reality but artistic
license gives me the right to do things
that reality doesn't offer things like
an illuminated seabed for example they
could dive down to the wreck a hundred
times but they never see anything like
this
Gattaca SEC worked on the Titanic
panorama for three years
born in Vienna Assisi now lives in
Berlin he was once a professor of art
but he left his job to dedicate himself
exclusively to his enormous paintings
and now he works for himself
[Music]
that's just great to be able to live in
a situation where you decide what you
want to do now I only do things that
genuinely moved me a C C's first
enormous panorama was finished in 2003
it was Mount Everest showing the world's
highest mountain from base camp
[Music]
the second project Amazonia came in 2009
like all of yadegar CC's panoramas this
one is made of printed lengths of
material this work allows observers to
slip into the world of the South
American rainforest one of his
best-known works was the war finished in
2012
it shows the divided Berlin of the 1980s
this panoramic painting is still on
display today in the centre of the
German capital not far from the former
border crossing at checkpoint charlie
last year yadegar CC began work on the
panorama Luther 1517 it is 15 by 75
meters in size will be shown for the
next five years in Luther's hometown of
Wittenberg it's bothered to see this but
I think each panorama has an energy of
its own after it's been shown it doesn't
belong to me anymore either this gate it
goes its own way
that's quite fantastic then when it's
all over and you've got some distance
you can barely remember making it
yourself there's not a nun compass
messed up in a month
[Music]
his latest work is being shown in the
pan ometer in Leipzig the former
gasometer
has the space to fit the Titanic
painting which is more than 100 metres
wide and 32 metres high
a documentary exhibition about the
British ocean liner accompanies the
painting as for the artist he's already
thinking about his next project one of
the next projects will be about me
getting really small so small that I can
sit on a flower and watch a be
pollinated and I'll do that in a
panorama just imagine a bee that's 15 to
20 meters tall visitors to the Leipzig
show can already start exploring the
details of Titanic passengers belongings
are even strewn across the seafloor with
this work a dagger Assisi wants people
to recognize that the wrecked ship
symbolizes the failure of humans to
prevail over nature